All kinds of interactions are present in the biological systems
Accompanied by adequate amounts of energy
But these interactions are not fast enough
Or even occur automatically
Glucose is a good example
We will address them in some detail
In the binary video interactions
Which we have already called
6. Phosphate phosphate
But this interaction is very important
When adding a phosphate group to the glucose fraction
The glucose portion is a basic input
For a whole series of vital reactions
The phosphate group gives the glucose and samma fraction
It makes it very difficult for the glucose molecule to come out of the cell again
This is done with a fairly clear mechanism
We have a free pair of electrons
On the hydroxyl group here
If this pair has a correct formation, it tends to
Composition of association with phosphorus atom
In the phosphate group
Now, what does not make this interaction happen automatically
Although it is more energy-efficient
Once it is bonded, the
Electrons move to a lower energy level
In other words, Delta G is a negative energy
If these particles are pre-interacting,
This is the amount of free energy available before the interaction
After the reaction, the molecules have less free energy
And you can release some energy
Which we would like to take into account
To be automatic, but in order for interaction to occur,
We need a little extra energy to be supplied in the equation
Which we call "energy activation"
You may wonder: why this?
Well, we have a pair of electrons wishing to form a bond
With this phosphorus atom
But the phosphorus atom is surrounded by negative charges
The oxygen atom present here has a negative charge
As you know, the electrons do not like
To be surrounded by similar electrons - because similar charges are repulsive -
So for this interaction to take place,
Or to be repeated
It must be stimulated
A catalytic agent is any substance that makes interaction happen faster
Or even allow interaction to occur from the ground up
If we talk about the catalysts in the biological equations
We are necessarily talking about
We are talking about enzymes
Enzymes
And how the enzyme stimulates this interaction
We are already talking about them
Also when explaining dual binary interactions
The enzyme may give some positive charges
May give some positive charges
Around these negative charges to pull them away from each other
To provide space or space
So that the interaction continues to occur
This is what the enzyme does
This curve changes - rather than being so rigid -
The curve becomes like this
Making the interaction continue to occur
But what are these enzymes?
These are the materials they can
It can make some important shipments
Which allows interaction to occur specifically
It can change the formation of molecules in a certain way
To reveal some links
It can be more acidic or base
Which is best to complete the interaction
What are these materials that seem to have magic effect?
Well, from a higher perspective, enzymes are often
Complex proteins - some other substances may increase or not -
So we can consider them proteins
Sometimes, they are multiple polypeptide chains
United together, may also be associated with some
Ions and other minerals, but overall,
Enzymes proteins, either molecules
Which will react
And combine with proteins,
We call it "pillars or reactive materials"
So these substances have this reaction, (words incomprehensible) glucose
And adenosine triphosphate (ATP), together form the substrates
You have to learn
That enzyme does it
The general term of enzymes
Which works on the sugar fraction phosphorylation like this
We call it "hexoxinase"
We will express this strange painting
This strange protein, we will touch
To him moments later
Adenosine triphosphate (ATP)
Here exactly
Adenophenyl triphosphate (ATP) is one of the pillars
The glucose part is then linked
Here exactly
These two interactive articles combine
While the area where all this occurs
Call it "Active Location"
Active site is where the interaction takes place,
Active site
Often where reactants are linked
RFID with protein
To make cohesion stronger
So that they become more
More
More appropriate to complete the interaction
The protein completely bent a slight bow
To approximate both molecules more spatially
What we call "motivational proportionality"
Proportion of catalyst
But what is the origin of these positive charges?
Well, materials may be like side chains
For example, different amino acids
In the polypeptide chain in the protein
Some ions may be entered into the reaction
In fact,
To facilitate glucose diffusion,
A magnesium atom is needed
To withdraw some positive charges away
But there are other positive groups
It can pull the cargo away from it
Opportunities for completion of interaction
So the enzymes tend
To operate at maximum efficiency in specific hydrogen-specific environments
Or specific temperatures
In general, the higher the temperature, the greater the number of interactions
Where the movement of materials and molecules increases more and more
But if the temperature increases even slightly,
The protein or enzyme stops completely from its function
Because of its changing nature
Or because it lost its spatial structure
The most I would like to draw your attention to is
How to meet the beauty and complexity of these compounds at the same time
Consider the splendor of what I offer you
This exists in all your body cells!
This is found in
Hoping in your hands, hoping
Everything is being around you, there are lots of
These things are going on inside your body, I hope that
Gives you an estimate of that configuration
Within you as a living being, as well
All living things (Hallelujah!)
We have a visual embodiment here
For hexoxinase, as an example
Let's take a bigger idea,
This is part of glucose
, This is the adenosine triphosphate here
The two are united together, these two articles
And unite at the active location
There may be a stimulating fit zone, where this is about
Some shipments are pulled away
May degrade molecules in some way
So as to increase the chances of interaction
Bring these materials closer together and more
Stimulate completion of interaction
Once the interaction is complete,
The bond between the enzyme and the reactants will cease immediately.
I find it better to release the name of the resulting material, at this stage
Here, each composite is separated from the other
Here is a change in the enzyme
This is a characteristic of enzymes in general
Its functionality is not limited to one use and then crumbles
Where he can repeat his job over and over again
One enzyme can do the job many times
During his or her lifetime
Now I would like to present to you a stereotype
Small three-dimensional - I got it from a website -
Let's show it now
I will stop my private recording here
So I can show this simple simulation model
In fact this is a model of hexoxinase enzyme
Hexokinaz generally
Available in various forms
But this model is superb and completely crossing
It was realized from a different perspective
If you search for photos of proteins online
Or anywhere else, you often see
On the model of the stick and ball model
And other times you find it in the form of a vacuum model
Sometimes you find it in the form of this type
Where ... This construction ...
Note here are alpha-type loops
Which we studied when we talked about the structural structure of protein
Here too you can see some chips of beta type
This gives you a better perception of
Where links are formed and how materials interact with each other
For example,
This is a part of the adenosine triphosphate
And who is next to him here - I think
If you look from a true perspective - this is a glucose part
Notice the bond between them here
They represent interactive materials
There is an association between them at active impacts
They can interact with each other now
The enzyme - in our case here is hexoxinase-
Facilitates the interaction we want to happen
Glucose phosphorylation
So I hope you give pictures like these or those
A vision of how beautiful and complex
These materials are of course their nature.